you saw the movie american-made right
with Tom Cruise no okay how bad this guy
Barry seals who was he was a CIA agent
they said that he would first say he was
an agent and worked for the cartel but
he ended up taking pictures of Pablo and
other other members from the making okay
and and he got killed right then putting
on trial I've killed the man that killed
him was a friend of mine ended up
becoming very close friend of mine he
died on Angola not too long ago in
Louisiana and he tells you the story he
got a degree in architecture and he was
barely making it and all his friends
were out there dealing drugs with girls
and nice cars and all that they invite
him one day to come and do a job with
him he didn't even know what it was the
guy is up killing somebody he didn't
stop tell him all this guy was a child
molester so he like here take ten
thousand dollars he said but I I didn't
come here to kill no one say yeah but
you came with me and from there on he
becomes one of the worst assassin the
cartel had killed tons of people always
justified that he's telling bad people
right that's how we do in life when we
cross lines we justify we had reasons
for what we do and so long story finally
is I was supposed to go to California
like I went every month and that day I
went up to my jet and when I went to put
my foot in my jet I start to throw up
and I went inside the office in the
hangar and and I had diarrhea man and it
was coming out of both hands and I would
like me I was sick I hadn't eaten
nothing I got up great I got dressed I
always would have breakfast on the
airplane right cuz we will leave like a
several o'clock in the morning to go to
California and so they would always have
a platter in the jet for me and so when
it felt a little better I went out and I
did the same thing and I told this guy
my right-hand guy I'm like Eddie you go
I can't go man I'm gonna [ __ ] all over
this plane yeah and Tom ago next week
and he and I are getting murdered they
were waiting for me and they murder him
and at the funeral I had baptized his
daughter like six months earlier and at
the funeral
the little girl sitting next to me she
say Godfather
my daddy went to be with Jesus and I'm
like it was the first time since I was
10 years old that I shed a tear I said
number one when will my daughter tell
that to someone I'll never see her again
and number two if there is if there is a
Jesus we ain't going there and and I
left and then I had a friend of mine
that had walked away from the marijuana
business and I had a big horse up and I
was making three million dollars legit
raising horses breeding horses you know
I was charging I bought the best Italian
in the world
paid a million dollars I was charging
300 feet bringing 150 mayors and then I
ended I went around we bought the best
brood mares in the country so and then I
had an orange drove that was going to be
making me seven million dollars a year
so I mean I was like set and about three
months past or so I used to kill with uh
with it how'd you get out cuz he used to
bring his merits to breed to my stud
he said well as I been pregnant George
you had a pregnant or not you had to
interrupt right I'm like all right and
rubbed it off and then the final straw
was I ended up my ex-wife got taught my
daughter to visit and I wasn't supposed
to visit with her and I was partying
with some movie stars in my house and
they call me from the gate and ate your
daughter's here so they bring another
mate take it to a Roman and Allah I have
breakfast would tomorrow morning and
when they take her to the room she
there's a room and I went back to my
party and all of a sudden but two
o'clock in the morning here knocking on
the door saying daddy it's crystal it
was the first time in my life that I
began to feel filthy disgusting you know
a guy that people used to say that ice
went through my veins I couldn't care
less about anything or anybody and I
just could not open the door because I
felt he's the only thing left in my life
that's pure and holy if I open a door my
contaminator
and I kicked Oh Pete the women out of
the window and uh and I went to shower
after I scrubbed the filth off of me
then I wasn't in my season I was
shivering and when I thought she was
quiet I ended up going to get water and
when I
oh she was by the full crying I said
enough that's done I'm gonna change my
life changes today and this is the thing
I told me about change I know what that
man well what what does change mean in a
life as complex as mine well all I know
is that if I'm going knows I'm gonna
start going south
[ __ ] I'm gonna eat I'm going west first
thing I didn't move out of Miami I
thought that the Sun rose and settled in
Miami to mean Miami was heaven right I
had power people respected me wherever I
go out he had to pay for nothing because
someone would pay for me and and I
called that night I called my mom and I
said I'm done and she knew what I meant
and she's like Jesus heard my prayer I'm
like no no no not to do with Jesus
this is crystal crystal and then the
next day I called and I'm I'm out I said
I didn't do nothing at that time all I
did is say send the airplane don't send
it in the high payoffs I had a guy that
rent our entire operation for me and I
said they come to me and they're like
well how much money do you want to give
yourself
I kept thinking about my guy seemed
pregnant or not pregnant so I don't want
nothing I'm out I just I said look you
don't want me no more because I've lost
it I love my nerd knowledge it was I was
just devastated my whole life was right
and uh and I left Miami didn't go back
for four years and I only 90 miles away
in my ranch and I lived a life that I
lived and I was happy man I you know had
tons of women got divorce had jets had
everything you know I spent two months
in Vail I spent summers in my house on
the UH on for miles beach then spring
Ivy had the horse shows all over the
country and then I'd be on my ranch and
that's it yeah and how old were you at
this point I was I walked away when I
was 29 yeah so no I was 31 I was really
one at that time so it's 31 33 34 I had
everything any human being
here's what I tell people we sacrificed
our life because we live in a world in
search of the American Dream which
doesn't exist right it's what I call the
pseudo American dream the American Dream
the real American dream was a World War
two generation you know that work hard
put their kids to school
save their money retire on one house
never got divorced they have marriage
problem but there was not an option
right they hated the war but to serve
was an honor they'd rather be an hour
early than a minute late people are
immense integrity that was the American
dream to build this most amazing nation
the American dream today is I want two
houses a bunch of cars a bunch of horse
you know money that and I'm happy the
problem is most people will die in
search of that dream and now realize
that if you're a reached that pinnacle
like I did you find that is nothing
there something I didn't realize why I
hated women went the most the woman I
respected the most in my life was my
mother
so you know and that's why I try to tell
kids today
I said don't sell out there's choices
and consequences there's consequence of
every choice we make that the material
aspect of a like what you just talked
about it influences so much you didn't
mean like why do why do you think today
that material stuff like that because
you mentioned even in your book that you
guys you and your family would drive
around rich neighborhoods and admire the
houses and the cars like that and you
thought that that was the main thing you
were striving for that was your
motivation to get money to buy that
stuff and it seems like so much stuff
especially like in media today that's
what drives kids is that material aspect
of it to motivate them to get from point
A to point B yeah and it is because
we're inundated with it from the moment
we wake up right we are told if you have
this you're gonna be happy if you have
this basketball shoes that goes down in
25 and oh you live in the ghetto you're
gonna be happy you'll be somebody your
identities identify with things with
material things right we don't realize
that we come into world with an
emptiness inside of us and society is
quick to tell you I can feel it for you
George oh you like that car Oh what was
your fake Corvette buy every single
model color think about which I did and
you'll be happy are you happy for a
moment but then you're empty again Oh
women who can be happy one women have
three four of them good a better when I
got married to my wife
when I gave my life to God I'm an
extremist right I don't know how to live
halfway I'm a really really bad I'm
really really good you're all inter all
oh they know I don't understand about
lukewarm you know when I became a
Christian I became celibate
now I'm here's a guy that went to bed
every day of his life with minimum two
women yeah and different women all of a
sudden becomes celibate for seven years
till I meet my wife and you know you
know what my prayer was for the two
years when we were engaged can I have
sex with just one woman now it's my
prayer because I didn't think I could
because that's how you demoralize
yourself that's how that's how sin or
bad choices or habits or addictions are
right look the problem is not cocaine
alcohol any other point none of that
pornography all of those are nothing but
medicine to try the society tells you
listen you're empty go get drunk you'll
be happy you know do drugs right so when
you go to start drinking you don't drink
a gallon of vodka right you and I all
right still a little bit a little bit
before you know it you drink a gallon
bucket you passing out and then you wait
till next week same thing pornography
you know same thing with any with drugs
you don't shoot an ounce of heroin
you'll be dead right there right and and
and we crossed lines lines that we'd
never think we could cross right and we
cross him and when we caused him to feel
bad and him because him again we don't
feel as bad like first time I cheat on
my wife I couldn't sleep for two nights
second time I think I always miss sleep
one night third time it was automatic
that's what I'm supposed to do
[Music]
[Laughter]